thaler vous aviez très justement il faut
s'intéresser aux pauvres dans ce pays
moi je voudrais qu'on s'intéresse aux
riches mais pas aux riches habituel jeu
on parle de solidarité je vois bien
autour de cette table qui a que des gens
de autour de cette table dans le public
et même les gens qui viennent témoigner
chez toi chez vous ils ont une envie
profonde de solidarité on est tous
d'accord moi je crois qu'ils les
frontons de taxer très lourdement
amazon netflix tous ces gens tous les
call cela dont on pas sur google ça je
pense que là il faudrait clairement moi
je serais presque pour un message fort
une fois prennent des mesures drastiques
drastique moi aussi je suis fort et
concurrence absolument déloyale à tout
ce que nous appelons communément la
culture c'est à la livraison de bouffe à
tout ça qui font une concurrence
déloyale et ça je ne sais pas mais je
n'arrive pas à comprendre comment il n'y
a pas une solidarité française qui à un
moment et ça ça dépend pas de vous même
appel à tous les citoyens
le dira peut-être qu'on va ralentir avec
ça parce que eux se gavent sans payer
d'impôts et l'effort solidaire qu'on
demande à tous les français aujourd'hui
eux ils échappent et voyez pourtant je
suis pas ni un effet à un rebellocrates
ni un révolutionnaire dans l'âme mais ça
je trouve que ça court un peu trop il a
parfaitement raison karim que les 1 %
des français plus riches payent des
impôts c'est normal on en paye tous et
c'est normal à dire merci à nos
coiffeurs qui sont les coiffeurs et
merci pour votre témoignage merci bon
courage merci à tous merci en train de
faire une pub son nom à netflix par
exemple en disant il ya des séries
magique extra bas qui payent des impôts
d'accord avec moi je suis d'accord avec
lui à fond à madame la ministre
important que vous puissiez rebondir sur
l'intervention la cnhi qui viennent
d'être faits sur les vingt ou trente
entrepôt de amazon qui sont en train
effectueront se constituer nouveau
supplémentaire
on a vu ça à circuler sur les réseaux
sociaux des jeunes qui s'insurgent et un
design et finalement notre petit
commerce est en train de mourir et à
mesure on va continuer à se déplacer
insupportable on accompagne d un
entrepôt d'amazon encore avec l'état
français et jean complète en rappelant à
libérer la ministre dans un instant et
jamal est quand même parce que c'est une
très bonne question
la première chose c'est que c'est quand
même du français
ce gouvernement le prévient marc et
publique brute de le maire qui ont été
les premiers les premiers au monde
taxé à taxer les plateformes galets
polis
et quand on veut et quand on est parti
tout ça elle et qu'on est monté sur la
crête avec notre petits drapeaux
américains sont arrivés on avait des
gens qui nous attendait et qui ont été
assez agressif il n'empêche aujourd'hui
non seulement on taxe ces plateformes
mais on a d'autres pays européens qui se
sont engouffrés dans la brèche
qu'ils soient prêts par des législations
soit on passait des législations
on al ocde qui s'est donc un organisme
international qui s'est emparée du sujet
lors peine à trouver une solution
et du coup on à l'union européenne oui
mais je pense qu'un qui fait que les
indices ont elles sont très lentes à
trouver oui je vous le dis attention les
genres oui donc on leur enlevait sociaux
et de leur doit bien oui on le voit
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il ya un
incroyable pour qu'ils soient pas taxés
sur et il joue voilà il
on voit ça avance avance avant chaque
match
oui non mais on se comprend bien le
président il avait pas l'excès dès le
début de son mandat
on ne leur en veux pas des triches moi
jeune homme ravi qui est des gens riches
et qu'il décide est magnifique et ils
ont tous eu alors à l'instar des cinémas
des finances et participer à l'effort
collectif bien sûr qui est celui de 2,2
tout le monde en convient
complètement d'accord il vous fait les
poches